sick in it
just sick
it sick it FedEx packages smashing
against his head oh who was that for
sick in
it break up with
him
Runk hello
hello
hello hello please
hello hello uh Earth to Chris yeah oh oh
episode 80 oops clicked out it episode
80 out it clicked out it but uh yeah
it's Sunday October 22nd Sundays are for
Lifeline go sign up for Lifeline luxury
that's that's what we do we do Lifeline
luxury man the last episode of Lifeline
luxury was actually Bonkers crazy good I
was I never think about the episode
after we do it I was thinking about it
all week yeah same it was it was good
last week last week's right patreon.com
Lifeline luxury uh stop with this Jordan
with the slam videos we got them all but
thank you very much I am on tour uh this
is going to be on the 22nd so I will be
in Fort Meyers and uh whoops why is it
not on whoops why is it not on the TV
whoops why is it not on the TV right so
so loud I know and I'm sorry and it
absolutely scared the [__] but was it
warranted I was already sweating a
little bit now I'm sweating more but was
it warranted I got it calm down but was
it warranted yeah yeah so Long Beach
California November 2nd whoops go down
Orlando Florida November 10th November
12th Fort Myers Florida Richmond
Virginia Baltimore uh Maryland you know
Trent New Jersey we got a bunch of
different ones but uh bore I'll be in
bore man bore in the house uh so that's
good with that and then um if you God
whoever's doing this needs to be quicker
huh it's interesting isn't that right
it's pretty interesting cuz we're done
with that so we go back to the gr we
go so have you got a question click the
link in the description below or go to
watch lifeline.com or just leave us a
message on the hotline which is uh you
know down there too uh one-onone advice
sessions with Matt go to mata.com and
Lifeline merch is at Lifeline merch.com
so there we go and that's it really I
don't think I've even one time done the
opening for for us that's so funny you
you've said some of the things in that
right but I've never I've never done me
you because it starts with my I usually
do my tour first I'm like why would you
why would you do that yeah yeah yeah I
was thinking we're recording at night we
don't usually record at night no we
don't and so this is a drama this
episode's a drama oh oh it's like a it's
got a genre prime time kind of yeah cuz
it's late and it's night time and night
time is for dramatic stuff right so I'll
just be like this Al okay that's not
that good you look have a stroke I I
it's not that good but I have a gun too
cuz I'm just like well it can be
dramatic without a gun where's the
where's the guy so bad where's the guy
who did it check it out so [__] listen
so [__] so listen freeze a face gun
what hurts my face so bad if I shot a
gun like that the Predator with this
thing um dork no absolute dork but I'm
not though uh what is the deal with
Seinfeld what is the deal with how I
went to I was going to be here early
okay didn't be decided it was going to
be I was going to be here too early
stopped looked for coffee I I wanted a
coffee bean I don't normally get coffee
bean anymore I get different ones really
you love coffee bean I know but I I I go
to there's pets and there's other
there's another coffee shop I like I'm
not going to say it but um that I go to
and I go there all the time and I don't
get coffee bean too much anymore what is
going on I mean I am happy about that
because I think that the Coffee Bean is
terrible it's not terrible it's like
drinking dookie in a cup it's not like
drinking dookie in a cup it's iced
dookie when that tastes is that coffee
bean mhm tastes like ice dookie hey like
this uh have ice dookie they would know
what you meant dude they would know what
you meant yeah
so so I went I I typed in I was on my
way here on the 101 I typed in coffee be
because I'm not really familiar with the
area coming here right I just know here
and home okay between here so there was
one a robot y y y
yeah so there was one uh I went there it
was a little bit out of the way but it
was okay where which one maybe I know it
um it was on like was it on I got off on
like Western or something is it up did
you make a left like go up on Hill it's
well you'll know when I tell the story
it's straight up in it's Korea Town oh
okay I know what I don't know it so I
was in Korea Town I I've never got I've
driven through a Korea Town I've been
driven through multiple Korean towns
I've never
got out and stopped in a Korea Town
before ever I don't think so that's
weird dude why because just for a number
of like even work reasons I've been to
Korea Town like meetings I back I mean
forever ago when I used to actually try
to act like there were auditions in
Korea Town yeah but but that's a little
different because when you go to
audition you're going to see people like
you which are white people if you go to
an audition for a certain part right so
oh you're saying mingling in ker town
you around a bunch of Koreans yeah also
Korean like barbecue restaurants if you
want like the real deal you go there so
I've never been but I went to Coffee
Bean and Tea Leaf which happened to be
in a Korean market the only thing that
was American there was the Coffee Bean
and Tea Leaf that's like uh uh Little
Tokyo has big markets small type places
and everything's Japanese so I went well
this was Korean but I went so that's
different so Japan is so uh I went to
this Market to get carabina tea leaf and
there was not there was one other person
that wasn't Asian one and I think that
person might have been Asian and then
there was I think it cuz I think they
were Indian but that's kind of that's
actually Asian right yeah so then there
was just me that wasn't Asian did you
how did you feel it was interesting I I
I I really
enjoyed it because I was like whoa this
is not like anything I've ever
experienced before just visually and um
then I was like it's kind of unfair
because uh wherever you go that's
technically white there's always not
white people around and Koreans have
that all to themselves places where you
go but I I feel like there's probably
places in the country where I mean only
and then there's like one black dude and
that now you felt like that one but
there's more than one
though I'm saying I bet there are places
where there's just one in the South
maybe yeah in the nobody will hear that
though so now they just think you said
oops for no reason I did O so uh
40 yeah it was really it was really
interesting though and I took a video
there and I sent it to Bobby Lee oh
because you thought he would like fit in
there well he's Korean and then I and
then I took pictures near some Korean
stuff very straightforward and I sent it
to him that's why I'm late sending
pictures of Bobby Lee you're late
because you were sending pictures of
Bobby Lee yeah okay and then he text me
back there I was a dip [__] for doing
that but I responded he never responds
to text yeah he's not a good texture but
um anyway so I was in Korea Town dude
have you have you done it I've done it
have you been in Kore Town something
like in a market like that uh I don't
know if I've ever been in a Korea Town
Market I started thinking about like
movies and [__] where like the the white
guy goes over there like to Korea or
whatever and is like just like the only
guy there that's like you know Out of
Water Fish Out of Water yeah and then I
started thinking like man what if I went
when I was like 21 and just moved there
and fell in love there and had a Korean
family out there when I was 21 and I
still lived there and I was 43 with a
Korean family and my kids were like
eight but
Korean you're asking me what if that
happen is that crazy dude we'd probably
have to talk limited Yeah well yeah I
guess we couldn't we couldn't see each
other as much we would not have this
podcast yeah and life would be much
different if I had a Korean family the
most in Korea obvious thing to say about
that life would be different that's very
true life would be very different it
would be even more different if you
moved to North Korea but oh yeah yeah
yeah well we never see each other but
now let me ask you a question when you
go into a Korean market why does it
stink like [__] what is that about that
huh it's just the cuisine it's cultural
I know is it weird it's the cuisine
cultural specific right but but but but
culturally they go in they go yum yeah
yeah I I had a Korean friend I mean
there's a lot of Koreans where we grew
up yeah you know to californ and there's
no Koreans in New Jersey but Southern
California a lot of Koreans
and yeah very very where we were was
half Korean yeah yeah um and you walk
into his house and just like yeah smells
like the back of a freezer a wall of Kim
it's kimchi that I'm smelling okay but
so kimchi is what I it's a smell that
like goes straight sh like puts a needle
in my brain I cannot handle it yeah I
used to date a girl who loved going to
eat Korean Barbe and I'm so not like
this I I actually I think about this
sometimes because I'm so not like this
and I think back to like I can't I can't
believe I did that but I can because of
what it's about okay I was like listen I
need you to stop going there whoa oh cuz
he would come back and smell like it for
a week oh come on for at least four or
five days really oh go backtracking
backtracking yeah at least four or five
hours after she so waa that's crazy so
so what I'm saying is okay so let's look
at this so what did you guys order today
chicken and like broccoli and [__] okay
to I walk in to
me I could understand how people would
think that that stinks like [__] but to
me I'm like okay that's food I can get
behind being it like yummy but if like
somebody out of our culture or whatever
the whiteness comes in they be like oh
this might stink like [__] right so yeah
of course yeah right so but okay so yeah
like uh somebody from Korea might come
in here and be like oh what is that
terrible smell yeah yeah yeah like we
how we do when we go to Korean markets
that it's very likely that's wild dude
isn't that weird it's all about
upbringing but it doesn't feel like it
because you go in and you're like oh my
[__] my mouth is watering I'm
so hungry but really it's all learned
it's all learned yeah yeah yeah [__]
dude I think about [__] like that all
the time yeah me too more more than me
more than you I think about it a lot
more and I'm I think much deeper about
Ito no I think about it like and I I
think so deep about it people can tell
how much I think and how smart I am just
because I'm like so deeply in you're not
thinking about it you're not even
talking about it oh my god look how
smart that guy is yeah well anyway dude
there were [__] so many rice bags
there it was crazy what the [__] is a
rice bag there was bags of rice with
just Korean letters on it what yeah
what's that mean I don't know they like
rice what do you mean but where was the
rice bag at the market at the [__]
Market just sitting around at the market
yeah they'd leave it on the ground like
chairs yeah but stacked up
just rice bags of rice yes okay like big
bags of rice you're thinking about this
wrong they're just big bags of rice but
where were they on the floor of the
market for sale oh okay well you didn't
say the for sale part not pissed oh well
they're in the market what did you think
they were I'm thinking of like a mall
where you go in there's a bunch of
different establishments including a
coffee mean including a little market
including a place where you can get ice
cream or whatever okay okay okay you
know what I'm saying yeah I get it now
but that was crazy all right well okay
let's do it you want to do a a thing
let's do a thing we'll get into the Bing
Bong I mean we're already we're already
coming up on 12 minutes let's get to it
okay okay who we got hey Chris and Matt
first off thanks for doing what you guys
do with this podcast and putting a smile
on my face along with so many others
each week second off I'm calling in
because I need some advice I work out 7
days a week every morning at this gym in
my town and about a month and a half ago
the gym closed down for the club scrub
which is like cleaning re organization
whatever so the day it opened they had
donuts for everyone and while I was
leaving I wasn't going to grab a donut
because I just worked out and didn't e a
donut but one of the trainers told me to
grab one so I grabbed two because I have
two little kids at home that would love
a donut and he made a joke to me like oh
yeah I bet those are for your kids or
whatever right well it was reality it
wasn't joke well since that day a month
and a half ago oh no I see him about 5
days a week and he has made a donut joke
to me every time seen it some days it's
oh is your protein doughnut flavored or
as I'm leaving he will ask me if I'm
heading to the jelly donut or one time I
was warming up on the treadmill and he
drew a picture of a donut on a sticky
note and came and stuck it on my
treadmill and he losing his mind hate to
rud I don't like awkward situations but
this is to the point like it is so not
funny and I try to avoid him at the gym
cuz I know a donut joke's
coming and I don't know what to say to
him so please help me out with some
advice thanks oh dude I have one
question to clarify is it her trainer or
a trainer no just a trainer at the gym
okay okay okay why dude this is crazy
how can somebody think that this is
still funny to do it's actually not
funny once but if you do it once or
twice I understand you don't really get
the language of humor you're just trying
to flirt with her you want to say
something three more than three times
dude you know how not funny it is it's
so not funny that a it's doubly not
funny in this way right it's not funny
cuz it's just not funny but on top of
that it's not funny like a character
like that would be in a movie in a bad
comedy who like does those that kind of
stupid joke and it's like even even as
like an idiot it's not like to make fun
of the person that's not funny that does
it it's not funny like that just sucks
in every level it is it is a four
quadrant sucker four quadrant suery it
is a four qu quadrant sucker uh and the
Post-it note that's just I almost feel
like he's trolling you but he's not he's
not right but but I mean that is so that
sucks man whenever this stuff happens my
first thought is always he's like in a
in a utterly boneheaded way just
flirting with well he yeah I mean he is
he wouldn't do it well maybe he might do
it to a guy I don't know I mean I get
weirdos come up to me do [__] like that
but maybe it's cuz they they maybe yeah
[__] like that yeah maybe cuz like like
like they know who I am or something I
don't know what does she say what how
does she get it to stop do not make a
donut joke anymore what do not make a
donut joke anymore and then he would
make a joke about how that yeah what you
say do not make a joke oh you said donut
yeah uh that's hor [__] that sucks dude
but what does she do don't cough
um
that's oh God I mean I would say that
like 85 to 90% of the time the advice is
just be straight up with the person
whatever you call in or you you you you
do video
in but you're just no matter what
honestly dude somebody who does that no
matter what happens you're going to get
guess what he guess what he gifted you
awkwardness no matter what yeah cuz now
either it's going to be awkward because
of the dut joke and you're going to have
be like or you're going to say something
and it's going to be awkward from then
on seeing him that isn't doing the donut
joke but here's the thing when someone
sucks that much why are you awkward why
you why do you have to feel awkward this
guy sucks I I I I understand that and
you and I get that but I get why she is
but I'm trying to con I'm trying to
convey to her like this guy sucks to
such a degree that it think about it
this way like let that minimize or or or
even totally erase the potential
awkwardness of saying hey stop like this
isn't funny you do it every time I see
you it makes me feel like I have to
laugh but it's so not funny I can't like
just don't do that but just yeah that
would be great if you said exactly or
well it would be or you could just be
like oh another dut joke great oh
another keep doing that he'll get the
hint but then he might think you're
flirting back or Worse do it more oh
you're right dude you know yeah if he's
like one of our parents friends I'll
tell you who it is later after the show
yeah dude that's crazy you know what
this is one of those [__] things it's
just too bad yeah it's just a shame you
know what it is you're a chick and this
is the [__] that chicks have to deal
with it sucks dude it sucks and I get a
little bit of that because you know when
I walk in somebody might make a joke
about something I did or you know
because they know me and [__] but man
being a chick is like naana dude it's
unbelievable you know sure it just like
being a man that's for sure yeah hell
yeah man that's not what I meant red
blooded American mans no mans you know
well uh I just yeah that's annoying
that's just some chick [__] it is you
just got to deal with it ah she should
say something well yeah but she still
will have to deal with it is my point
even after yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but if she's going to have to deal with
it anyway she should say something don't
ever pretty much ever talk to anyone at
gyms pretty much that is the rule it's
pretty much the rule but uh you know
maybe like oh you're using that or oh
you obvious you canate
no write little notes uh yeah yeah uh
that's that's tough man he just how do
how do people not know that rule that
seems like one of the most obvious rules
that there is there's no obvious rules
people are dumb especially men well
obviously but saying that seems so
obvious it's it's it to break that rule
you got to be a big ID there was a woman
there's a woman at my gym and she comes
in you know she's a little older um she
always seems No Nonsense
do not approach me uh in the zone works
out hard it's cool
and I was just like that's a woman that
you don't does anybody hit on her
uh have you ever seen some uh no I
haven't seen anybody do it no I've seen
her like three or four times
right um I am I I noticed she's on the
machine that I want to go to right okay
so I'm I'm not gonna ask her when she's
done I'm not gonna I'm just gonna assume
that you know she'll be done and I'll
pick it up right so I go to uh stand
kind of near it but not to where she's
like oh he's waiting for it do you know
what I'm saying okay so I go there and
uh I I have like half of a water bottle
full and I there's a wall and I go to
kind of like instead of bending it down
and placing it on the floor I just kind
of like Chuck it over there to see if I
can get it to stand up against the wall
I'm also very very very out of breath
because I out like a monster okay now
you're getting sidetracked in a way I
don't like at all my delts they get big
when I work out I look very [__] I'm
look massive so I do it and I go oh and
she
says
uh wow somebody's angry so loud whoa and
I it [__] me up so much because she
did not seem like somebody she was
making like a being silly oh yeah not M
you know cuz I wasn't angry I was just
she was making a joke like oh you threw
it down hard and I was like I didn't
know what to say and I finally mustered
out oh yeah dude I would have been down
and put it put it on the ground but no
extra movement except for the exercises
it's all for the exercises and she
went really loud like not like that but
like you know what I mean and I was like
you never really can judge a book by it
cover know dude you know never know yeah
no it's true yeah she's very sweet I
mean I'm not making fun of her I'm just
you could not have guessed that yeah
you're crazy so uh uh why do I say that
I have no idea Jim related I guess why
did I say it probably just because you
wanted to talk about being at the gym
because it's all you ever talk about
every video you send me which is often
you send me a lot of videos throughout
the course of the day is always of a
buff
guy doing something and it sucks so much
that you send me that and I tell you all
the time time why do you s me this I
don't want to see this I don't care it's
not even at all something I'd ever want
to look at 2 hours later maybe less you
send me another
one those guys are too big I mean I know
but why are we looking at fascinating
dude dude it's not that fascinating is
fascinating because they're too [__]
big and it's obvious what are they doing
that big why always looking at them you
look at him so much but CU it's just
fascinating 20% of his day he's looking
at really big buff dudes yep that's I
mean not 20% but a lot I just 20% but
it's not wow it it it's not a oh that's
great thing it's just like what the [__]
yeah a lot of them are short and you're
like what well if you're going to be
that big be big and tall dude no but I
mean I think the obvious thought I know
I yes yes but guy we we can see what's
going on here I mean some women like
that though some women are into
that really buff a limited amount of
women I
thinked limited edition I think it's
more than a little amount minuscule
amount it's it's it's why do they do it
because dude they're [__] why does
the guy write Donuts to the [__] lady
why do think he's being funny cute
delusional just like the other [__]
short big dudes right but no dude okay I
mean I don't know how to prove it but
this is my actual belief I think more
than we realize cuz obviously my whole
life I've never been like a big muscly
dude and I in PE guys in my friends in
my Orbit are not either so I don't
really have any experience with how
people but I my sense is that why else
would guys do that to their bodies if
not to like enhance their chances
with in what significant other whatever
but that doesn't mean but okay we're
talking you're talking about
muscles on muscles yeah am a good body
is different no I know yes we're talking
about the same thing yeah no I had one
girlfriend that I dated that was like I
I like that I would date a guy like that
and I was like no like really really big
and she's like yeah I think it's I think
it's good-looking there you go and I was
but that's one out of oh my God how many
girls have I dated dated seriously not
that many not that many like you've had
you know not that many anyway I'm a
lonely Soul I'm AOL anyway I'm right
okay well whatever yeah okay next
what's up guys Chris I saw you in
Phoenix in Salt Lake stalker a stalker
you're one funny guy thanks dude I'm
kill anyways I have a bit of a concern
okay I have a very high sex drive but my
girlfriend has a very low sex drive and
I'm probably going to marry this
woman and I I don't want to cheat on her
and I don't want to be jacking off all
the time that's just weird to me anyways
you
what I'm not sure what I should do any
advice would be helpful thank you guys
meditate and
jacket meditate in your jacket meditate
in your jacket Jack jacking it isn't bad
I I I don't I don't really get it I
don't get Jack
is
often healthy yeah I don't jack it I
have a guy that I hire that comes over
and uh Jacks it yeah he jacks it okay
well that's good it's not gay cuz I'm
watching porn straight porn right but um
no I don't uh I don't think Jack it is
that bad honestly I I I I uh I never
used to do why who thinks Jack and bad
besides religious people well no well no
I don't think he's religious he's just
saying I don't want to be jacking off
but why not well I don't know but he
probably wants to have sex instead which
I get that that it's better I guess
course but the reason you're jacking it
is so that you can have that release M
and
remain happy or or whatever even killed
whatever you want to say so Weir to call
it a Rel not like what so weird to call
it a but then that's literally what it
is you got to like let it a lit single
it's like it's like imagine like there's
a sealed jar and something inside it is
expanding yeah you got to open the top
and let it out the way you're talking
about you know mean what it's so
sexy you know what I'm saying like you
got to have that you got to let that go
but also you're not supposed to bust
that much so I would ask this guy how
much how great really is your sex drive
are you trying to bust like three four
times a day well that's no good I mean
even every day is crazy to me I that's
crazy it is yeah but you're not even
supposed to I mean no according to like
tantric whatever you know you're not
you're really supposed to hold it in so
that like the power of it once you do
you know let that release out of your
pee hole oh man chill I'm getting a
boner um I I think uh one time I was
talking to I guess I was I was out of
high school at that point but we I was
talking
to I God I remember I was at my friend's
house and one of the guys said what's
the most you masturbated in a day and I
don't know I don't I don't maybe you
know maybe when I was like that age
maybe
twice I don't think any more than that
but um oh really twice I mean there were
six sick days when I was in high school
where like like when I was actually sick
in bed I mean at least five times oh
really no I've never done that really
not after being a teenager but like back
then yeah oh no I never did that so uh
he said the most I've done is 11
ooh first of all how long are you awake
yeah yeah that every hour what a maniac
huh yeah I know who he is of course you
do you had the conversation with him I
know that man I I believe I wonder who I
wonder what he's doing now jerking off
well he's probably not 11 times but
probably still pretty healthy no I mean
right there this second he's probably
dring off that'd be weird if he was
right yeah 11's too much but like here's
the thing when you're in a partnership
like that whether you're the man or the
woman or if you're in a gay relationship
doesn't matter then you'd be mad you
have to only have sex the amount that
the person who wants it the least wants
it that's just the bottom [__] line
so like no what what I'm saying is
there's no advice to give dude you just
got to learn how to [__] less because
you can't [__] some else obviously and
if you don't want to be Mr jacking it
then yeah you're [__] out of luck buddy
yeah okay there's nothing else to do
that is right that's the only that's the
only thing to say and you're right
that's it okay next
one what's up Matt what's up Chris love
you guys love Lifeline I watch every
week I love congratulations been
watching for a long time now um my
question today is I'm in the Army and
I'm up here at Fort leis Washington and
we have a Transit service that's like an
Uber it's free it goes anywhere on Bay
so it's not like a super long drive at
all um and I use it a lot I know most of
the drivers uh but there's this one guy
who's always seems like he's in a bad
mood not you know not the kindest guy
doesn't talk a lot um so today I got
this driver and I I get in the I get in
the vehicle the van and uh I'm playing a
I'm playing a video on my phone like
it's like a Tik Tok video it's pretty
low volume I can barely really hear it
uh but he turns around and he's like you
good and I'm just I look at him I'm like
yeah yeah are you good like what's going
on kind of made me laugh and he's like
can you put some headphones in or turn
that video down and I'm like yeah yeah I
just I laughed I was like yeah my bad
dude um but he's always kind of just in
a bad mood I just I didn't know maybe
maybe I should have said something else
you know to try to cheer him up I guess
but no you know I try to always be as
kind as possible you know CU these these
guys you know that's this kind of their
job but he's you know no music playing
no just silence uh and that's his you
know if I'm an Uber driver right I'm
going to be listening to music I'm going
to be blaring
but yeah know he got mad that I was
playing a Tik Tok video I mean as soon
as we left too like 5 seconds after we
left the spot that I got picked up at
you know he was already mad so I just I
I don't know maybe maybe he was having a
bad day I don't know but I just try to
be as kind as possible I just you know
in my mind as soon as it happened I was
like it's a pissed right yeah but uh I
just thought what would you guys do in
that situation if you get into like an
Uber and you're listening to a video on
your phone and the Uber driver looks at
you and he goes can you turn that off
yeah you know s dick right I just try to
be as kind as possible times what you do
um I'll watch every week appreciate you
guys love you take you're the man dude
thanks so much thank you thank you bro
appreciate you what a good spirit good
energy said the same thing nine times
but it's all good so go ahead uh I if I
got into an Uber yeah and the driver I
was playing a video as I got in slide in
the seat close the door starts after
five SEC and after 5 seconds before the
video is over yeah he turns to me and he
says you good yeah and I somehow make
the connection that he's saying because
of my video I would I don't think I
would by the way well he did so I'm
assuming I would too whatever and I
would I would definitely laugh either
naturally or
because I would I would process it and
be like wow I have to respond in a way
that is to measure with how big of a
dick this guy is and
I want to laugh at his face I would like
make a choice even if I didn't do it
naturally yeah yeah I'd pull his head
back yeah I would laugh because like
you're you're a crazy guy you you're so
deeply like perturbed at all times yeah
that the slightest annoyance uhuh at
your job to technically people who
you're working for yeah well that's the
thing it's like an absolute [__]
dude like imagine how miserable that guy
is is I want to talk go like uh the
adage the old adage the customers always
right of course they're not always right
but that situation you're working for
them you let them listen to a Tik Tok
video if they want to yeah you're the
driver so if that happened to me I would
say do do you think that this video is
too loud I'd have questions for the guy
and then I would and then I would say
something like like are you upset with
the fact that I'm listening to something
at all or are you upset with the fact
about how loud the video
is okay because I would want to know
deeply I would want to understand what
this guy's gripe is and you think he
would answer you I don't know but I
would ask that and then I would say uh
is is something bothering you today
you'd like ask how he is not because of
a good person because I'm like what's
going on
oh no yeah uh I would say like why are
you asking me like that well actually
with the context that he gave I might be
like if he did that to me I might be
like why are you so miserable all the
time yeah I might just like immediately
in response ask that like what's wrong
with you dude like why do you have to be
so M I ride with you sometimes you're
miserable what's going on like stop yeah
that's probably I would do something
like that too that's good you don't want
to like clap back at him too hard
because that's like you could be okay
[__] here we go dude do that and
then you don't want to be you don't want
to turn into the aggressor but anything
to reflect hold up a mirror back at the
guy is is good in that
situation you know what I'm
saying yes I do know what you're saying
and you're right but that's crazy yeah
well I do agree though don't listen
to well you know what that you know what
you know what's awful though
FaceTiming that really is annoying when
people are doing that in public yeah but
you you're it's his job again he's not
in public you're right you're right
using a service that is a part of his
army base when he's right right he's on
FaceTime I would want to get off my
FaceTime before I started like
broadcasting it to some stranger right
just cuz I'm private but like someone
has a right to get into an Uber with
while they're on FaceTime yeah you're
right who cares just drive the [__]
you're right you're right you're right
all right okay next
one hi Chris hi Matt my name is Sophia
I'm a huge fan of the podcast Chris I've
been a long time congrats fan I'd like
to consider myself an original baby hell
I was so excited when you guys started
lifeline and I've been waiting for a
year until I had a question that I
thought was good enough to submit cool
and I finally do so I was recently
rewatching Cast Away with my boyfriend
um and some of our friends and about
halfway through the movie he said
something that I thought was just
[__] crazy which was wouldn't it be
sick to be stranded on a desert island
and I said basically immediately without
even thinking I'd rather [__] die
yeah and a lot of people took that as
like super morbid which I get but like I
am not interested in surviving a [__]
plane crash surviving a plane crash into
the [__] ocean yeah and then also Sur
surviving in solitude for 5 years on an
island and then like I'm not even that's
bad enough I'm thinking beyond that I'm
thinking like what happens when you
reassimilate back into society and you
have like trauma and PTSD and like night
tears and you'll never get on a plane
again it sounds awful so let me know
would you guys want to survive
interesting question would you do you
guys think it's morbid that wouldn't
want to I mean he pulls his [__]
tooth out yeah so let me know well I
don't think it's morbid because you're
just picking you feel the lesser of two
evils I wouldn't I would dude I mean I
would I would run that Island dude well
there's nothing to run uh well that's
why it would be easy but I would I would
figure out how to run it dude I'd figure
out how to run it and get it going and
and if it and when I came back in five
years dude oh dude I would be so
interesting to everyone so that's all
that's all gravy man well that's true
you would be interesting to everyone but
you be like a like a I'm getting back
what I'm getting back I would get back
oh I see the ocean is the by far the
scariest part yeah but here's when he's
laying in the [__]
whale remember that part the blow hole I
like that mie yeah that movie is cool
you like it yeah yeah movie is great
when he's trying to fish in the
beginning you know it's no it's cool no
that's a great movie yeah all right the
Wilson part is amazing uh but here's
soundtrack all right don't be like that
dude now I'm getting pissed here's my
gripe what [__] absolute
[__]
[__] [__] idiot watches
Castaway and says I would love to
survive on a deserted is what the no
what she said was it' be so sick to be
on a desert island sick and it okay
that's very over to say he's a [__]
[__] he is cuz his brain doesn't work
dude his [__] brain does not work you
know how [__] awful that would be you
know how [__] shitty it would be if
he was around someone who that actually
happened to and he said I wish I went
through what you went through you know
how [__] rude that would be this
guy's a [__] idiot he's he's not able
to use his brain be careful of that he's
probably just talking what if what if
the whole plane went I mean it's so
gruesome too the way the plane goes down
and [__] it's so scary and then he's
just sitting there he just going and
when it happens he just goes sick and it
I mean what did you that guy did she say
it's her boyfriend yeah her boyfriend
yeah break up with him no no no he's out
he's out it would not be sick to be on a
stranded on and everyone knows that so
he's out it's not he's probably just be
trying to be cool in front of his lady I
don't know he's out on an Umpire he's
making conversation like he's out he
probably wouldn't mean it's if it was
sick he'd just go do it he doesn't mean
it's sick dud another reason why you
shouldn't have said it sick and it
just sick
sick it FedEx packages smashing against
his head oh who was that for sick is
it break up with
them break up with them Sophia or Sophia
I didn't catch the N would you rather
but would you rather
die well that yeah okay that is a
separate issue the question for me was
break up the first part was break up
with that guy there was a glaring
problem there so but would I rather die
m
here's the qu my question in response am
I guaranteed to survive I knew that that
was what you were going to ask if that's
if if I'm guaranteed to survive of
course I would not want to die she's
saying she actually would rather die cuz
even possibility of not the life would
be ruined which I totally actually I get
that with that but I wouldn't choose
that I would I wouldn't have P pity for
that yeah you would everyone every
single person would every single person
would the plank the plane crash alone I
would get right back on a plane I would
have to dude I know a guy who was in a
plane crash and then got right back on a
plane and then crashed again no okay see
there you go no but that's not anyone
that's not any where's
doctor you're fixed um uh yeah that's
crazy Jesus yeah and he told me the
story right before I got on a plane what
an [__] yeah wow it was crazy just to
hear the story I was like oh
planes don't crash though let's face it
well I mean doesn't happen well it does
it's never happened in the history of
planes okay now you're lying yeah okay a
lot of them just disappear too which is
scary as [__] chrisa here we go Chris
deia oh that was short short video
what's up that's a good question okay
play it do it
better up man Chris so I'm looking for
advice in regards to my father
um long story short he's been in and out
of my life um we had a fallen out in my
late teens saw who he was as a person
wasn't a fan split for my mom when I was
really young for domestic violence
issues anyways he goes to prison um not
too long ago I'd say like five or six
years ago for like attempted kidnapping
attempted sexual assault domestic
violence again um he got out and he's
been shooting me text ask him you know
how I've been give me updates on his
life um and I haven't responded to him
the thing is I'm really close to his
family's family's really close to my
family um I've just been toying with the
idea of just blocking his number um so
I'm just wondering what you guys think
and maybe the advice you give me will
help someone else with a a strange
father so um but yeah what do I do how
do I
react do I block gone for five years I
don't know anyways uh Matt you rock
Chris you rock I really appreciate this
podcast been a fan uh since it was
created been a baby forever um but yeah
thanks guys later you know I think that
uh I mean the whole point of prison is
sub it changes you so IDE but as we all
know it only makes more criminals I know
but maybe there's a shot you know I I
don't know it's been 5 years I would
sure say give him a shot and because see
maybe he's different but his experience
with his father counts that he didn't
get too far into that if
you don't again I said I said this about
last week to someone else about
something else kind of similar but not
this drastic if you don't want to
be family is amazing and if your
family's good or even just kind of okay
you're lucky okay right most people in
most families have real problems with
their immediate family members and you
obviously are one of them but the truth
is you don't
need
to be in touch or involved with your
immediate family it's not necessary
don't feel like guilt true or whatever
the [__] I'm not saying you are but if
you're considering responding or letting
him have a chance just because he's like
knocking on the door and you think you
owe him that you don't you absolutely
don't only respond and engage if you
want to yeah if you want to block him
like you suggested earlier absolutely
just [__] do it and say [__] it and
never think about him again if you don't
want to right if you want to have him in
your life cuz you think it might be
interesting cuz maybe whatever for any
reason doesn't matter whatever your
reason is then do it and get guess what
if you respond and then he responds you
start talking a little bit and it sounds
like it's going maybe okay and then he
does something you're like oh there's
that again you can block him then it's
all [__] fine the only good thing
about a situation like this is that you
hold all the power and you get to do
whatever you want and not feel bad about
it that's the [__] deal he [__] up
a whole bunch he [__] up with your mom
he [__] up with you he [__] up
obviously with other people after you
he's a [__] up and I'm sure he'd be the
first one to admit it just because of
that doesn't mean he's not going to [__]
up anymore he could and then you have
every right to block him again okay I
this that was good advice and but still
without me this podcast wouldn't be as
good wow okay okay just 100% making it
about you no that was that was great
that was great advice I mean that was
really good it was almost like you have
a daytime talk show I do I do a good one
um yeah no I agree you know but he is
human and you might feel bad if you do
block him so but you don't have to there
you go mhm that's all good Matt Matt
said it really really well yeah cool
good luck that's [__] up
yeah all right guys how we doing it's
Malcolm from Scotland here hope you guys
are good uh there's one glaringly
obvious thing stand out about me is this
flipping beard um so I'm just looking
for a better of dice do
I keep it or do I just go not keep it
and baled as you can see [__] bus
driver waving to me that that's you know
from a small town man wow I love this
guy so much I do I keep it it's coming
into winter and I love to ride my
motorbikes so it kind of fits the
aesthetic of that yeah or I just [__]
get shot at this band boy I'm driving
just now very very recklessly cuz I'm
[__] concentrating this damn video
boy W love your [__] H what does he say
which part all of it he I heard sh shave
his beard or not and he said I'm driving
recklessly because I'm focusing on the
video and he laughed I did not hear that
part and whatever he said it not it
wasn't about the beard should I shave it
or cut it did not hear it he said the
bus driver waved at him and he said a
lot of things I'm surprised that's what
he said there wow you speak Scottish
yeah I speak Scottish Uh I that guy was
great honestly think he looks and look
what do I know because I've only seen
you one time time I think your beard is
great mhm and it looks like you are a
guy I this sounds stupid because you are
a guy with a big beard but you look like
a guy who has a big beard you know what
I'm saying yeah you have the energy of a
guy with a big beard and it seems like
if you got rid of it you might be like
not energyless but missing something and
you might feel not naked literally
because you will be more naked than you
were before but like sometimes people
have such a specific identity I had a
friend in high school whose dad had this
crazy [__] thick Ned Flanders
mustache yeah and he shaved it like a
few years later and I saw him again I
was like you're not you dude you're not
you I see you I hear you you're talking
to me we're catching up you're not you
so you don't want that to happen but
then again beards go back so whatever if
you're asking should you shave it
because you want to shave it then you
should shave it but if you're asking
does the beard suit you it looks
fantastic that's a great beard great
beard yeah I mean it's redish it's no
gray yet it's just fantastic strong
beard yeah I don't think you get rid of
it dude strong guy strong Vibe strong
beard strong energy okay you got it
going on yeah you're in a truck you know
you're in a truck you're happy you're
laughing you're [__] got a great
Rogue is it uh annoying to have a beard
like that you never had a beard like
that right my experience with with
beards obviously no I've never had it
like that is that the longer it
grows the less annoying it is
really until it gets to a certain point
and you're like now it's like in the way
that's how it is with my
penis the longer it grows the more
noising it is and I got and it gets in
the way and you know what I mean the
more noising it is okay cool it's not a
word but that's all good uh yeah yeah
okay yeah I think you keep it unless you
really want to obviously do what you
want but yeah I my vote if it's all the
same to you is keep it what about my
brog do you think my brog is good you
don't have one what is that I don't know
why there's some [__] like this that I
think about all the time brogue is I
don't know if it only means this but
it's only used when people talk about
Scottish accents yeah it's like pregnant
women people say pregnant women are
beaming they're beaming it's like don't
use that word I do people don't use that
word in other scenarios but they always
use it about pregnant women I do there's
some word no you don't I do when did you
say beaming I go dude that that dude is
beaming okay if he walks in a room and
he's like really happy like man this
dude is [__] beaming my name is
Willie Willie beaming as for the women I
keep him creaming so gross you know what
that's from yes I do Any Given Sunday do
wow Jamie Fox Oliver
Stone good job why why were you saying
brog just
now absolutely destroy me dude I want I
got one I got a a question for
Matt why' you say broke it's the next
video no why why were you saying brog
isn't that what isn't that what a brog
is shoes what brogue is shoes no no no
no but you're right yeah so why what he
saying I don't know what he's saying may
they might be shoes as well what you
were saying why you were saying it his
voice oh yeah Gunna oh so absolutely
destroy me
okay
I I I don't know so Furious furious with
gonna pass out in for 20 seconds and
convol a little bit all right let's do
it do it I can't help it I know hello
Matt and Chris um first of all I'm a
huge fan of both of you um Chris I've
loved you since you made fun of Lenny
Kravitz's scarf and Vine and Matt it's
true what they say you make Chris better
this is the best podcast in the world a
um all right to get to my
question or my advice that I need is uh
I am pregnant with my fourth child and
um Chris you might remember um you
recently did a uh Cameo for me because
oh um my sister-in-law can't come to my
baby shower and um it was hilarious but
um I not all of my kids names start with
a j including mine and my husband's
which might sound really [__] weird
cuz it is but it was unintentional the
beginning it just kind of happened that
way and when you start to have a couple
of the
same else your kids will feel left out
eventually like I don't know you're
right good good good your suggestion was
jeroy we're considering it oh I remember
that but um I remember this my question
is how do do I address when people
comment about all the J names because I
don't bring it up because I don't think
it's like a cool thing I think it just
is what happened and it's kind of
embarrassing because it's kind of stupid
but stupid it is what it is don't be
embarrassed yeah so rather than getting
into the entire details of like why it
started and why we kept doing J names
what do I say to people because it just
gets so repetitive and everyone's like
why and I don't want to be compared to
like the Duggers the worst family on the
face of the planet but um I didn't know
they did that yeah just need like a good
maybe funny simple comeback for why we
decided to stay with J names for my
entire family yeah it was awful uh
that's it thanks so much guys love you
both thank you love you too uh yeah
you're the you're the best just be like
I mean I I understand that that would be
annoying but you could just be like well
we're both we both have J names we
thought it was cute to name our kids
here's the thing it's not
true in situations like this my advice
and in my own life I do this as well
when when there's a question that annoys
me that I get a lot I give the simplest
quickest answer even if it's not true
right so to for her to have to explain
she'd have to use a lot of words because
it wasn't intentional and they didn't
mean to and now they keep perpetuating
because they don't want to leave feel
make any kids feel left out too many
things to
say me and my husband both have J names
we thought it was cute to name our kids
J names bye bye bye-bye
bye-bye okay and then you're done do
that though do the bye I think that what
I think that
um I okay so here's what I think about
that so in my family it's Chris Christen
Calvin when I we named him Calvin I
didn't mean to have another C Sound
I just liked the name Calvin she said
you know we're all cuss sounds so for
the fourth for the well for the the
second kid you want to do that and I
said no yeah cuz I don't want to do that
but that's where you have to nip it in
the butt right there if you have two
kids with the c and we're all C and then
a third kid that's what she's saying
yeah right I know but I'm just saying
let's be clear on where it stands so
once you're in after two I agree she's
got two more it's just worse and worse
you can't have a like Steve after that
and I wouldn't have thought of this I
don't think but she's right I think when
she says if you don't if you abandon it
at kid number four or three they're
going to be like why wasn't I named that
way the second one's fine because nobody
but also with you it's cckk right it's
different anyway right yeah um and I
only like three cuss sounds KKK like
that I mean you
know okay
um so yeah so I was like no this dud
William will call him Billy so there's
not even close to it there's not even a
K in the whole thing right correct yep
correct
bilky Killy so what's your advice for
her change their names change their
names because the question is so
annoying yeah change them the way I
think when somebody says oh like first
of all what do you think they're saying
like I don't get oh did you mean to do
that or oh they're all Jays huh people
just say the thing that come to their
mind that comes into their brain that
they know that they actually don't even
know that they think is going to be like
a good thing to be a conversation what
they never consider and this is the real
shame is how obvious it is that that's
what pops into other people's brains too
people think they're special and they
have special brains they don't mhm
everybody's brain is pretty much the
same and everybody pretty much has the
same first thought when they meet
someone and they a family and they all
have J names so guess what skip
commenting on that because you know damn
well everyone comments on it okay go
ahead yeah I think you could go like
this what was I supposed to do right
that would be great yeah that would be
funny too get really defensive yeah oh
you have four oh you have also all six
of your jays yeah what was I supposed to
do yeah that's funny dude uh yeah D I
hold them by the shirt and say what
would you have done over a building
right yeah yeah come up with me up to
the top floor after they ask look at
this dude I got a house over there what
was I supposed to do what are you saying
about what I'm saying about back down
there on the second floor when you ask
me about all my me and my husband are J
names and then also my kids are J names
we get so tiring to do for every one of
them you have to go to a building when
you're not near one you know yeah you
have to work out you have to arm curls
for and work on your cord it's core
strength you could coax them you don't
have to force them what do you mean no
you do when you have to pull them out
like this oh right right right yeah okay
yeah core strength holding them over the
building got it got it I I'll send you
some Instagram videos of some guys
videos yeah wow dude I think uh I think
uh I think that's annoying but also it's
one of those things that you had to know
it was
coming he speaks the truth oh hey look I
can't believe it took look what
Anthony's doing can't 53 minutes into
the thing he's going go a potty he never
ever doesn't go plopski
during a recording of the show he goes
plopski every single episode usually in
the first 10 minutes I'm
shocked that he did not go plopski you
think he's going 45 minutes of course he
is we won't be able to tell cuz it maybe
that's why he got broccoli cuz now we
won't be able to tell him about plop
skis what do you mean cuz broccoli
smells like plop skis oh so you see with
his o you think he's that smart I don't
yeah me neither but he could have got
broccoli this is what probably really
did have got broccoli then was like oh
dude I got BR I could probably go [__]
no I don't think he thought that far I
think that's less smart than less smart
than planning it the whole way
premeditative pre premeditated pre
premeditative what's up so do we want to
do another one or we done yeah we got
another one or no no we're done oh wow
shut it down immediately dude so you can
you can blame Chris Moo if you're into
the episode you can blame Chris MCO that
it stops okay it's not us it's not our
fault at all
at my DMs are open the what I said my
dmms are open wow you know wow with his
feet up you know so his feet are up dude
he said my DMs are open by the time this
episode airs it will have been my
birthday oh yeah huh yep I'm turning 15
years old no I don't so and I look way
older than excited to finally be 15 I've
been wanted to be 15 since I was 10 just
5 years ago so it's the stupidest thing
anyone ever said so I'm really looking
forward to that GR
and and uh yeah by the time you guys
watch it I will have been 15 for 3 days
well I can't wait to celebrate your 15th
birthday on October 19th on October 19th
I will be in Pittsburgh right I think
I'll be in Pittsburgh you will be in
Pittsburgh on my birthday and then I'll
be in Cleveland and then and only then I
will be in another place I forget
Detroit so wait you'll have your this
won't matter because it will already
have happened but it's Pittsburgh on the
19th then Detroit the next night or
Cleveland the next night I believe so
yeah wow why why is that wow busy busy
yeah but well that's what I always do I
know I know that oh but don't you also
stay places for weekend oh you can drive
oh everything's closer than it seems
yeah Rust Belt cool dude the uh I do
stay sometimes when I'm doing a club or
or multiple nights like if it's a big
city for me like Boston or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cool
all right well oh they took it for sure
we're going to find out took too long
took too long to flush well no that's a
that is a that is a plopski that's what
I'm saying okay what do you mean that's
what I'm saying I didn't know you I
sorry I took too long to flush yeah but
what does that mean took too on to flush
for a piss right okay cuz if he pissed
he would have flushed way before that
absolutely and it's 100% very obvious no
it's not really you didn't do it right
you didn't say the things in the right
order I did mate uh good for you I did
um sick in it all right so that's it
that's it for the episode happy birthday
Matt happy birthday happy b day happy b
day um and then that's it like like And
subscribe dude oh and and go to
christ.com I'll be at Fort Myers I'll be
in Oh Long Beach I'll be in and don't
forget
patreon.com Lifeline luxury yeah it's
where it's at it is sign up now
yes
hello
[Music]
helloo
hello
hello hello